une annonce qui ne plaît pas en france
le champagne désormais rétrogradée en
vin pétillant en russie le terme
champagne sera réservé aux seuls
producteurs russes décision de vladimir
poutine résultats le groupe lvmh menace
de suspendre ses livraisons les
précisions avec notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman les consommateurs
russes de champagne français en retenu
leur souffle pendant le week end les
journaux russes diffuser le scoop la
maison moët hennessy comptait suspendre
ses livraisons de champagne en russie
pour une période indéfinie en cause de
nouveaux amendements la loi signée par
vladimir poutine vendredi dernier sur la
régulation de la production d'alcool
le chef de l'union russe des
viticulteurs et des vignerons russe a
qualifié la décision de la maison
française de chantage et lui a proposé
de ne pas livrer sa production
s'il refusait de se conformer aux règles
ruche je pense même que c'est une sorte
de chantage sans aucune preuve du
champagne fourni en russie par une
vingtaine d'autres fabricants et aucun
d'entre eux ne s'est indigné si vous ne
voulez pas livrés ne livrait pas les
vins mousseux produit en russie ne sont
pas pires nos consommateurs ne seront
pas privés devant pétillant d'une
qualité égale
dingo est un art sommes comparables nous
n'oublierons jamais qui que ce soit a
donné aux produits alcoolisés un nom
différent de celui que le fabricant lui
même utilise
nous demandons juste de prouver qu'ils
se conforment aux normes russes
concernant le vin mousseux et de
l'indiquer sur l'étiquette
en effet en vertu des nouveaux
amendements la classification des uns
est réalisé selon le système russe
caractérisée par des indications
géographiques protégées et des
appellations d'origine protégée et s'il
existe bien dans cette classification en
champagne russe à 6 que je pense que
cette dénomination ne peut pas être
utilisé par les importateurs la pause
dans des livraisons du champagne
français qui auraient effectivement lieu
sera donc dû au fait qu'il faudra
désormais apposée sur la contre
étiquette de chaque bouteille
l'invention vin pétillant encore
bloomberg moët hennessy compte envoyer
de nouvelles caisses dès que possible
pour rappel la russie importe près de 50
millions de litres par an de champagne
et pétillant dont 13% de champagne
français la parts de la maison moët
hennessy et de -2 2%